estamos en el prado en madrid y estamos
admirando la gran obra de velázquez las
meninas y no lo digo únicamente por sus
dimensiones porque efectivamente es una
pintura muy grande sino también porque
contiene un gran cuadro adentro del
mismo tamaño que el cuadro mismo algunos
historiadores del arte sugieren que
velázquez porque observa que hay un
autorretrato de velázquez en el acto de
pintar está en efecto pintando la
pintura que estamos observando me sigues
ya sé que es muy complicado así que lo
que vemos en el centro del cuadro es a
la infanta rodeada por las damas de
compañía una enana la institutriz y
otras personas que al parecer están
atendiendo la y en la parte del fondo
hay un espejo un enigma en la pintura
sabemos que es un espejo porque es
diferente a las pinturas de la pared
posterior es una superficie más
reflejante podemos ver sus cantos
biselados y dentro un reflejo del rey de
españa felipe cuarto y de su esposa
algunos historiadores del arte han
sugerido que podríamos ser ellos mirando
nuestro propio
reflejo otros señalan que el espejo
refleja en realidad la imagen que velas
que se está pintando en el lienzo y
otros más sugieren que está reflejando
el lienzo pero el rey y la reina están
de pie digamos dónde estamos nosotros y
esa es la razón de por qué la infanta
está mirando hacia el frente e incluso
el perro está pendiente por eso la
atención general se centra ante todo
donde estamos nosotros ante la pintura
quizás estamos en el espacio del rey y
la reina pues fue pintada para el
estudio del rey quién sería la persona
que la contemplaría es decir está hecha
para su mirada y ese tema de observar de
la mirada es para mí uno de los temas
centrales de la pintura me sugiere una
conversación de miradas de personas que
reaccionan a las miradas de los demás el
acto de ver en sí mismo como un ensayo
sobre la forma en la que vemos y también
sobre el acto de prestar atención porque
recuerda que estos son el rey y la reina
de españa uno de los países más
poderosos sobre la
de la tierra en aquel entonces es decir
que tenías que prestarles atención
cuando entraban en la sala y los
ignoraban bajo tu propio riesgo y
podemos observar al artista velázquez
pintor oficial del rey observando a su
vez a la pareja real él tenía por
supuesto el mejor trabajo que un artista
pudiera conseguir en la españa de ese
entonces pero a mí me interesa su
sentido natural y de espontaneidad el
sentido de informalidad tan inesperado
en un retrato real eso es lo más
sorprendente de esta pintura lo que hace
tan difícil decir lo que es y la hace
tan llamativa es decir que no es un
retrato porque sabemos lo que es un
retrato las paredes circundantes están
repletas de ellos y son retratos muy
formales de la familia real posando y
luciendo su gran poder pero este es
diferente tiene cierta informalidad como
de escena cotidiana algo así como un día
en la vida y el estudio del pintor pero
tampoco es eso porque también es un
retrato entonces en cierta manera
transgrede la línea entre uno y otro
ambas cosas a la vez es un retrato
íntimo que en cierto sentido te permite
penetrar a un momento de verdad en la
vida de palacio de hecho algunos
historiadores de arte han señalado que
fue pintado para autopromoción del
artista y así poder exhibir su
importancia y valor en la corte
por otro lado surge la idea de que como
pintor no es solamente un artesano sino
una intelectual pero entonces aquí
tenemos una ironía cibeles que se
intenta promover la idea del artista
como intelectual y no como artesano la
persona que trabaja con las manos en
cambio es un magnífico ejemplo de
pintura nunca podemos subrayar el hecho
de que es una pintura fantástica pese a
que las figuras transmiten gran
naturalidad el cuadro no es tiene una
serie de trazos de pintura y eso se ve
muy claramente en las mangas de la
infanta y de su institutriz y
especialmente en aquel rayo de luz un
trazo blanco que baja por la manga del
artista y arrastra a nuestro ojo hacia
la paleta y aquí hay un enigma
maravilloso
la paleta es una representación espacial
de la pintura pura la materia que el
artista utiliza para crear la imagen de
lo que es lo que me parece muy
interesante también es que hay momentos
en que ocurre lo contrario
mira la forma como su mano sostiene el
pincel es pintura pura que prácticamente
se disuelve que se rehúsa a formar los
dedos de la mano en cierto sentido está
jugando en el límite puede hacer trazos
muy suaves con el pincel que se aclaran
y unen para formar la formar la tela en
movimiento
luz reflejada en tafetán o cualquier
cosa o puede incluso disolver la forma
que prevemos y permitir que aquellos se
convierta simplemente en el acto de
pintar
y creo que a esto se suma el hecho de
que no vemos lo que está pintando
hay una especie de misterio sobre la
alquimia de pintar de cómo te vales de
un medio y solventes y pigmentos y los
conviertes en realidad
sin embargo no está buscando sólo la
realidad creo que está buscando una
cierta realidad condensada una
experiencia intensificada del acto de
observar de la intimidad de esta familia
y este momento y creo que está haciendo
algo que es muy poético y muy filosófico